et c'est parti pour un nouveau stream de
sciences sociales aujourd'hui c'est
mardi classique donc on va parler d'un
camp classiques des sciences sociales je
l'avais annoncé dimanche il s'agit de
laisser sur le don de marcel mauss je
pense qu'ils étaient neveu de 2 km si je
ne me trompe pas voilà ça c'est vraiment
un classique sipa de sciences sociales
en tout cas d'anthropologie
très très intéressant alors ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui
c'est que moi je vais lire dans mon
bouquin parce que j'ai surligner dans
mon bouquin c'est un petit peu ma
manière de lire j'adore surligner dans
les bouquins et j'adore les surligneurs
au 6
août que jour ce qu'on va faire c'est
que je vais aller chercher maintenant on
va les voir ensemble sur le net pour
voir le pdf et pour le partage et au
chat comme ça tout le monde pourra voir
le texte gratos sous les yeux si vous le
voulez mettre sur son banc je lirai et
donc pour ce faire je vais juste changer
la vue
je vais aller dans la fenêtre de travail
je vais ouvrir une fenêtre
edge
et l'a sélectionné
voilà très bien alors si vous ne
connaissez pas ce fabuleux site je vous
invite à aller vous promener sur les
classiques des sciences sociales qui est
un site
canadien
qui propose à tous les utilisateurs
une quantité innombrable de classiques
des sciences sociales mais aussi de
philosophie donc c'est vraiment chouette
parce qu'on peut regarder un petit peu
les textes sans devoir forcément acheter
le bouquin ou à la bibliothèque ou que
sais-je là tu sais que tu vas trouver de
nombreux textes alors si vous aussi ça
vous intéresse fait un don ça vaut
vraiment la peine et si tu vois ta les
auteurs classiques moi j'avoue j'ai même
pas encore été dans les autres onglets
salut phoenix va bien
depuis deux jours et donc ici s'est
classé par auteur donc là je vais aller
sur m comme mos
osk et
max marcel mauss voilà
et donc je laissais sur le don
[Musique]
est quand même pas mal de trucs
c'est sur le don ben voilà qui est un
texte et ça je la pris récemment ouais
ça va super quoi
super super besse je suis en congé
demain donc je te dis pas comme c'est la
fête
laissé sur le don en fait c'est une
publication qui a été fait dans l'année
sociologique je pense donc de 1924 1925
et je trouve que c'est un très bon texte
qui va nous servir de base quand on va
lire marx parce que je compte me
remarque en tout cas le premier chapitre
du capital avec vous ici et donc il ya
des choses que je pense que moss nous
apporte bon et aussi si molle qui est
intéressant à lire pour compléter
finalement une analyse marc sienne
mais je ne sais pas si on ira si mal
parce que c'est vraiment chiant
alors ici voilà vous avez laissé sur le
don le problème de ce site c'est que
parfois il ya quelques petites coquilles
donc ça
c'est gratuit n'a pas trop à se plaindre
mais voilà on a tous le texte ici
alors je vous dirai dans quelles parties
on ira donc je prends le lien
et je vous le mets dans le tchat
voilà
au cas où vous voudriez suivre sur le
texte ou le lieu où le thériault -
évidemment
alors où on est d'accord aussi que ce
genre d'exercice
mais totalement un parfait 1 parce qu'en
fait je vais saucissonné le texte et
c'est pas c'est pas top de faire ça mais
qu'est ce que tu veux on est sûr twitch
aussi si tu veux vraiment avoir un cours
de sociologie fait de la sociologie ce
tu veux faire d'anthropologie fait de
l'anthropologie ici on avait l'accord
que c'est quand même une initiation
et donc que c'est forcément perfectible
voilà
j'ai le texte parce que tout simplement
je lis dans le bouquin donc je vais pas
pouvoir suivre les deux les deux choses
en même temps donc
ça aussi ça sera un parfait mais voilà
c'est comme ça c'est la vie dans la vie
n'est pas parfaite
alors est-ce que je là je suis dans
[Musique]
parce que je prends la collection
quadrige que j'aime beaucoup parce que
je trouve que les bouquins sont jolis
longtemps biotech ça fait joli j'aime
bien le papier
c'est un peu plus cher mais les
introductions sont parfois un peu longue
ici je n'ai même pas lu
introduction de florence des verts était
prédestinée à faire des sciences
sociales
et donc je vais lire quelques petits
éléments que j'ai plus aurait de l'intro
de marcel mauss mais voilà je sais plus
trop pourquoi je les ai fluorés g par
lui forcément l'intro gérer vu la
conclusion est donc on ira de surprise
en surprise mais ça un petit peu le le
jeu un toute façon ce qui est
intéressant c'est celle et développement
que nous allons faire
que je vais faire ou que vous allez
faire
voilà alors je me ravitaille juste avant
de commencer
je devrais aller au ravitaillement
pendant le stream je pense
alors ce qui est intéressant dans le don
en fait
la première partie du bouquin est
relativement chante moi j'ai pas aimé ça
m'ennuie
il décrit vraiment ce qui se passe dans
certaines
dans certaines civilisations première on
dans le pacifique notamment en amérique
du nord et j'ai envie de dire que son
style et
c'est forcément vieux mais par exemple
je préfère nettement lire durkheim que
ici laissé sur le don j'avais juge
jamais lu marcel mauss
et donc il va nous parler un certain
moment de la cula on y reviendra je vous
montrerai une vidéo qui explique assez
bien ce que c'est la culasse est
vraiment très intéressant et le potlatch
alors ça c'est vraiment les deux trucs à
connaître si tu fais d'anthropologie la
culotte le potlatch
qui sont des phénomènes sociaux totaux
nous avons conscience sociale on étudie
des faits sociaux 1 selon durkheim
dürckheim un fait social c'est quelque
chose qui exercent une contrainte sur
les individus qui est extérieur est
antérieure jean vit aux individus
qui va les contraindre donc avec une
certaine stabilité donc on évite
l'écueil du cas isolé et moi je rajoute
j'ai envie de rajouter qui est
avec des interactions qui est lié à des
interactions un système d'interaction ou
un système institutionnel bref à quelque
chose de social un social ça renvoie
l'interaction alors ça c'est un point de
discorde avec certains certaines
parfois je me fais un petit peu commenté
sur youtube pour me dire oui mais bon
des faits sociaux le critère de
collectivités c'est un peu obscur je
suis désolé mais bon comment tu tu
expliques alors certaines choses qui ne
sont pas des faits sociale si tu ne peux
pas les
les écartés grâce à ce kit erla style tu
vois le
le tabagisme
enfin comme le départ si le tabagisme
finalement c'est quelque chose de
l'extérieur aux individus qui exercerait
une contrainte qui a une certaine
stabilité mais pour moi le fait
tabagique le fait de la dépendance à la
nicotine le fait de fumer et quand même
quelque chose de plus individuelle et
donc tu vas pouvoir travailler se fait
ou pas en fonction de le considérer
comme quelque chose de collectif si
c'est la dépendance il n'y a rien il ya
rien de collectif est donc là tu ne lui
travaille pas comme un fait social par
contre si tu considères que le tabagisme
c'est lié à l'industrie du tabac à l'
influence de ton groupe de pairs et bien
là ça devient un fait social et tu vas
tu sais ce qui est social dedans donc en
tout cas moi mon niveau comme prof du
secondaire c'est super important d'avoir
ce critère de collectivités qui
intervient
et donc marcel mauss formule quelque
chose d'assez intéressant en lisant que
le potlatch et on verra encore une fois
ce que c'est plus tard est un fait
social total et donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose à mon sens qu'il faut
retenir de cet essai sur le don c'est ce
concept de fait social total et on verra
plus tard de quoi il s'agit 1 pour
rappel ici je suis dans l'instruction et
donc je vous explique un petit peu ce
qu'on va faire aujourd'hui est ce qu'il
y a dans ce dans cet essai
ce qui est dit aussi c'est que
finalement tout le questionnement elle
c'est là que c'est intéressant pour
avoir après une réflexion de type ou une
critique de type marxiste sur notre
société c'est que tout son bouquin en
fait c'est de poser la question est ce
que le marché est un phénomène
totalement humains anthropologiquement
humain donc c'est à dire pas forcément
ça marche et c'est un phénomène humain
mais dans le sens est-ce que c'est lié
intrinsèquement à l'homme et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que j'ai mis en titre
de ce stream l'argent et le marché
sont-ils profondément ancré dans l'être
humain alors outre le côté un peu plus
ta clique et je m'en excuse du titre en
fait c'est vraiment le questionnement de
moss
qui se pose la question est ce que le
marché est humain est ce qu'il n'existe
pas d'autres formes que le marché pour
réguler les échanges de biens et de
services entre les individus et donc sa
réponse est évidemment oui et comme en
sont le cumul la cula et le potlatch ce
sont des bons exemples de phénomènes où
les hommes les femmes vont échanger des
marchandises sans toutefois qui échange
d'argent et de monnaies et donc qu'on
soit dans un phénomène de marché et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est un essai sur le
don parce que c'est un contrepoids un
contrepied au phénomène mercantile qui
serait quelque chose peut-être pas
d'opposer mais de différents marchés
nous ici dit le carreau marche est un
phénomène humain qui selon nous n'est
étranger a aucune société connue mais
dont le régime des changes est différent
du nôtre
alors ici rap
dans certains cas ce sont les
collectivités qui échangent et contracte
quand il existait des formes
précédent la société
marchande et capitaliste toutes les
formes de marchés antérieures étaient
plutôt des démarches et qu'ils étaient
faits par les collectivités doc là il
déconstruit déjà ce concept de marché
c'est ce qui nous intéresse
de plus ce qu'ils échangent n'est pas
exclusivement des biens des richesses
des meubles des immeubles des choses
utiles économiquement ce sont avant tout
des politesses des festins des rites des
services militaires des femmes des
enfants des danses des fêtes des foires
dont le marché n'est qu'un des moments
et où la circulation des richesses n'est
qu'un des termes d'un contrat beaucoup
plus général est beaucoup plus père non
permanents donc voilà il relativise le
poids du marché
et donc il nous dit que c'est ce site-là
son nom des systèmes de prestations
total qui dépasse largement le marché et
dont le potlatch est un exemple
voilà ça c'est un peu pour
l'introduction et pour le contenu
général du bouquin alors je vous ai dit
les premiers chapitres non pas trop plu
en termes de lecture j'ai pas ça a été
pénible est donc plutôt que de les lire
j'ai trouvé déjà il ya un certain temps
une chouette chaîne youtube qui
vulgarise pas mal de
d'anthropologie et aussi de philosophie
et donc on va regarder deux vidéos qui
nous explique ce que sont la cula et le
podcast alors cette des vidéos qui sont
assez scolaire j'ai envie de dire parce
que le lait youtuber est aussi un
professeur lui professeur dans le
supérieur
mais je trouve que voilà c'est très
clair et donc c'est pour ça que les
choses
alors je lance youtube
et je vous le dis fusent
juste après
alors peut-être regarder d'abord
l'épisode sur l'aquila qui dure six
minutes parce que il l'a fait dans ce
sens là
il faut savoir que marcel mauss
apparemment lui n'a pas voyagé et donc
il se base sur différents travaux et
notamment sur les travaux de malinowski
qui est aussi un auteur intéressant et
c'est en cela que je n'ai pas lu mais
voilà moi j'ai pas une formation en
sociologie à la base ni en anthropologie
j'ai fait d une licence à l'époque en
sciences politiques donc voilà comme ça
vous savez tout est donc je lis au fur
et à mesure de mon avancée dans la
découvrir des sciences sociales avec
vous ces différents auteurs
voilà allez
je vais lancer sa
voix là et maintenant je vous le mets
sur
la fenêtre de travail
fe
s
vous allez avoir la sortie oui je pense
si je fais ça
vous allez avoir la sortie
non ça ne marche pas
bon
le ca
bon comme vous le savez ça fait deux
mois que j'ai pu stream et à part
dimanche et donc je me remets tout
doucement
à l'utilisation de bs voilà je pense que
si je fais ça
fonctionnera
hop ça c'est bon
alors c'est un podcast 1,2 twh n'ya rien
à voir bonjour à vous
la description à l'interprétation de la
cool hein un terme qui signifie cercle
dans la langue des habitants des îles
trop brillant constitue le coeur du
célèbre ouvrage de l'anthropologue
polonais bronislaw malinowski
les argonautes du pacifique occidental
un livre qui paraît en 1922 c'est par
ailleurs et depuis lors une notion
devenue à peu près incontournable pour
tout étudiant en anthropologie
telle qu'elle est décrite par malinowski
l'institution de la kula désigne un
grand système des changes qui concerne
une trentaine d'îles et de sociétés
différentes dont la disposition en un
large cercle constitue un circuit fermé
ces îles sont situées au nord-est de la
nouvelle guinée
ce système des changes complexe et
pacifique consiste à faire circuler deux
types de biens deux types d'objets
considéré comme précieux mais pourtant
dénué de toute utilité pratique et de
toute véritable valeur marchande en
l'occurrence des brassards de coquillage
blanc et des colliers de coquillages
rouge qui vont s'échanger les uns contre
les autres pour d'étape en étape
atteindre les participants les plus
éloignés avant de finalement revenir à
leur point de départ et recommencer un
cycle celui ci pouvant avoisiner une
dizaine d'années les brassards et les
colliers qui n'ont donc aucune fonction
utilitaire circulent en sens opposé en
formant deux flûtistes
l'écolier circule dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre tandis que les
brassards circule dans le sens inverse
chacun de ces objets suivant sa propre
voix dans le circuit fermé rencontre
l'autre sur sa route et s'échange
constamment avec lui tous les mouvements
de ces parures en coquillages tous les
détails des transactions sont
rigoureusement codifiée par un ensemble
de principes et de convention est
certaine de cette transaction
s'accompagne de cérémonies rituelles et
public parfois extrêmement complexe et
c'est pour ça que moss appelle ce
phénomène là des phénomènes sociaux
totaux
parce que ils sont à la fois
économique en quelque sorte parce que
c'est quand même un échange de bien même
c'est pas forcément des biens
utilitaires mais ils sont familiaux
juridique esthétique religieux et alors
je pense que dans la vidéo il n'en parle
pas trop mais vraiment ce qui est
important et moss insiste là-dessus
c'est le côté que quand tu échanges
l'objet tu ne changes pas que l'objet
pour ces personnes l'objet est lui même
chargé un petit peu de l'esprit quelque
part du donateur ou des anciens
possesseurs mais je pense qu'il va
évoquer ça et c'est très important parce
que
moss insiste là-dessus et c'est ce qui
fait qu'on est face à un fait social
total
sur chaque île dans chaque village un
nombre assez restreint d'individus
participe à la couleur c'est un
véritable privilège que de pouvoir
prendre part à cette activité noble et
ça apporte un énorme temps je vais
essayer de régler la fenêtre parce que
je vois qu'elle est raboté et c'est pas
sympa
mais je comprends pas pourquoi j'arrive
pas à la
[Musique]
halle augmenté
je ne sais pas et si je sors du mode
plein écran je vais peut-être rester
comme ça
les noms de prestige mais cela se mérite
à force d'alliance et d'appui et à
partir du moment où on est engagé dans
le système des changes ont ils restent à
vie comme le dit le dicton une fois dans
la kula toujours dans la cool
le participant qui est souvent un chef
reçoit la visite d'un autre participant
ça doit être quand même bon
voilà et un côté un peu dans
l'anthropologie l'ethnologie je trouve
qu'il ya un côté ben voilà un peu
paternaliste et c'est un peu c'est quand
même un peu spéciale avec nos yeux de
2022 de repenser à ces expéditions dans
lesquelles il avait observé ces tribus
première où ces peuples premiers mais ça
devait être quand même impressionnant
toi avec ton ton logiciel était
référence européenne ou autre et
d'arrivée d'observer des systèmes comme
cela avec des yeux voilà
curieux et observateurs ça doit être
quand même un truc incroyable quoi
qui à cette occasion lui offre un des
objets en question brassard ou collier
ce qui est remarquable ici c'est que
celui qui reçoit ne donne pas de
contrepartie immédiate
il se contente de recevoir il se
contente d'accepter le don qui lui est
fait et c'est fondamentalement ce qui va
différencier le don de l' échange
marchand c'est le côté différé du contre
don parce que évidemment il ya toujours
un moment où tu vas
rendre comme chez nous le cadeau qui t'a
été offert en offre un cadeau
d'anniversaire mais tu offre des cadeaux
vos anniversaires des autres mais c'est
considéré comme un don même si la
rétrocession au final parce que il y a
un côté différé il ya un moment donc il
peut être plus ou moins longs entre le
don et le contre don donc ça c'est super
important on le retrouvera aussi dans le
potlatch
il détient l'objet par exemple un
collier pendant temps variable mais
relativement court parfois une année
avant de le transmettre en apparence de
manière désintéressée un autre
partenaire des changes en respectant
bien sûr le cycle propres à cet objet
pour l'essentiel est qu'il n'est jamais
permis de bloquer un objet de la chaîne
de la couleur il n'est jamais permis de
garder trop longtemps un collier ou un
brassard et a fortiori il est
strictement interdit de le conserver
indéfiniment le site donc c'est vraiment
ça aussi c'est un point de différence
avec nos sociétés marchandes ou voilà le
une fois que tu as vendu un bien ou que
tu as acheté un bien tu le gardes et
c'est pour toi et tu peut accumuler les
biens ou là où l'argent des ventes de
thé bien quoi c'est une grosse
différence circuit des échanges ne peut
jamais s'interrompre on reçoit un objet
on le détient temporairement puis on le
transmet sans payement ni marchandage
après un certain laps de temps celui qui
avait reçu par exemple un collier
devient lui même donateur d'un brassard
un autre partenaire encore tout en
respectant le cycle propres à cet objet
il s'agit donc bien d'un système basé
sur la réciprocité
mais une réciprocité qui est différée
dans le temps et qui est indirecte les
brassards et les colliers s'ils sont
tous considérés comme relativement
précieux n'ont pourtant pas tous la même
valeur
différents critères comme la taille
l'ancienneté la patine des coquillages
assiko leur histoire interviendront par
exemple les objets les plus prestigieux
et les plus sollicités lors des échanges
sont souvent ceux dont on sait qu'ils
sont passés entre les mains de tel ou
tel participants renommée ils ont donc
une certaine valeur matérielle
parce que j'insiste ces objets ont en
quelque sorte pris un peu de l'esprit de
leurs anciens propriétaires ou de leur
ancien détenteur ça je pense qu'ils
n'assistent pas suffisamment dans la
vidéo maintenant il est plus qu avec man
en anthropologie mais dans la lecture
c'est ce que j'ai ce que j'ai compris en
tout cas mais aussi et surtout une
inestimable valeur immatérielle
mais à quoi servent précisément ces
objets pour lesquels les participants à
la cool avons déployé beaucoup d'énergie
et consacré beaucoup de temps dit
pourtant n'ont pas de réelle utilité
pratique ni de valeur marchande avec la
mise en lumière de ce système des
changes basé sur la réciprocité différé
malinowski illustre sa théorie du
fonctionnalisme
l'institution de la kul a fourni en
effet l'occasion que se remplisse de
nombreuses fonctions au sein de la
société parmi lesquels alors on peut
être faire une petite parenthèse sur le
fonctionnalisme c'est un paradigme en
sociologie en sciences sociales donc un
paradigme on dit souvent ce sont les
lunettes
du sociologue ou de la sociologue sait
plus ces prismes à travers lesquels tu
vois la société alors c'est pas
forcément terre présentation c'est
plutôt vraiment le parti pris que tu
prends pour étudier la société le
fonctionnalisme c'est un paradigme qui
va être très en vogue
depuis durkheim durkheim sur certains
points et un peu fonctionnaliste jusque
merton talcott parsons aux états unis
la moitié du 20e siècle et donc si on
peut prendre une métaphore
le paradigme fonctionnaliste tu vas voir
la société comme un organisme comme un
organisme vivant d'ailleurs
dans les travaux durent km ou dans son
bouquin sociaux de ce2 méthodologie qui
s'appelle les règles de la méthode
sociologique dur keim a fait toujours un
lien avec la biologie et sur les
fonctions cas sur les choses et tu vois
c'est ici voilà pour
malinowski la cula
assure une certaine fonction comme pour
durrrr came
le comment dire le suicide assure une
certaine fonction mais je sais pas si
ici l'exemple sur le suicide est bon
mais par exemple dans notre société à
nouan fonctionnaliste dirait un maintien
l'école existe parce qu'elle permet la
socialisation tu vois c'est un peu ça le
fonctionnalisme
avoir des échanges marchands socialiser
les individus animer la vie quotidienne
maintenir la paix entre les différentes
sociétés faisant partie du cycle des
changes établir une sorte de clans entre
les partenaires d'un échange permettre
des rencontres sceller de nouvelles
alliances amical et politiques
contracter des mariages organiser la vie
économique naître entre banques je
rappelle si vous arrivez maintenant
marcel mauss va reprendre ses travaux de
malinowski en nous disant la kula le
potlatch sont des faits sociaux totaux
parce que il met en jeu où ont ils
mettent en action plutôt toute la
société dans toutes ses parties et dans
toutes ses composantes
après on essaiera de penser s'il existe
encore des faits sociaux totaux j'ai un
peu réfléchi je pense que c'est même une
question je vais poser aux élèves de
rhéto mais voilà
c'est pour ça que c'est un fait social
total en thèse la notion de propriété
mais aussi indiqué le rang de chacun
dans sa communauté et apporter à ceux
qui s'adonnent à ces échanges
prestigieux de la distinction du panache
de la renommée et donc dû voire sociale
une valeur qui dépasse de beaucoup la
satisfaction des simples besoins
élémentaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'anthropologue marcel mauss considérera
la kula comme un fait social total dans
la mesure où elle constitue un système
global des changes à la fois culturelles
économiques sociaux politiques
magique symbolique et esthétique
je vous remercie d'avoir regardé et
écouté cette courte vidéo
bon c'est vraiment propre alain bazot
mais je lui avais laissé un petit
message je sais plus sur quelle vidéo
pour le remercier mais m'a pas forcément
répondu je pense ou alors je m'en
souviens plus mais franchement si vous
aimez des sciences sociales abonnez-vous
à sa chaîne parce que c'est vraiment un
chouette travail je trouve qu'en pour
les étudiants notamment
parce que voilà il va il va résumer
différents classiques comme ça où
différents concepts et je trouve ça très
propre en fait
et donc on va regarder aussi le potlatch
mais est ce que il y aurait dans nos
sociétés actuelles des faits sociaux
totaux à l'orgie un peu réfléchi comme
je le disais et je me demande si
certaines manifestations folkloriques
où les personnes sont très mobilisés ne
sont pas des faits sociaux totaux moi je
pense notamment à une fête à côté d'eux
de chez moi ma ville la ville qui est la
plus proche de chez moi
qui s'appelle fc le doudou 1 c'est une
grande fête à mons alors oui forcément
je vais tomber sur des choses à l'actif
de présentation du doubs si vous ne
connaissez
en gros ça c'est le moment fort c'est le
combat de saint georges contre le dragon
salle de doumé il ya aussi tout un côté
religieux bonjour événement parce qu'en
fait tu as une procession religieuse
avant il ya aussi des concerts qui sont
données est vraiment toute la région
s'arrête de vivre pour le doubs ce week
end là et tu as les forces de police qui
sont bien sûr mobilisés il ya des
règlements on change les plans de
circulation
donc est-ce que tu ne peux pas
considérer voilà des manifestations de
cette ampleur qui mobilise vraiment de
manière très profonde les gens
s'invitent les uns chez les autres donc
c'est aussi un phénomène familial les
enfants participent parce que une
semaine après il ya le petit doudou pour
les enfants donc vraiment où les toute
la société mobilisés mam je pense que
dans les maisons de retraite les maisons
de repos on sort les pensionnaires pour
qu'ils voient passer les différentes
choses donc c'est vraiment toute la
société qui est mise qui est mobilisé
dans ses différentes dimensions et je
pense qu'on pourrait considérer ça comme
un fait social total maintenant c'est
une analyse comme ça très superficielle
vite fait donc je ne sais pas mais je
vois pas d'autres éléments qui qui
serait un frère un fait social total
donc dans lequel pour moi on verra la
même définition tout à l'heure de marcel
mauss toutes les ce toutes les
catégories de la société sont mobilisés
et dans lesquels ou presque toutes les
catégories et dont toutes les dimensions
possibles
la question reste posée alors le
potlatch
alors je rappelle que en fait ces
concepts là dans la première partie du
bouquin marcel mauss nous expliquer
reprend les travaux de malinowski
revient sur ces concepts en les
analysant mais j'ai trouvé ça assez
pénible et donc je ne veux pas les lire
en direct c'est pour ça que je me base
sur les très belles vidéos de
vulgarisation d'alain bas jamais et puis
après on lira plus tôt la conclusion de
marcel mauss
sur toutes ces analyses
bonjour à vous le terme potlatch est un
terme qui signifie donner dans la langue
chine où qu il désigne un ensemble de
cérémonie pratiqué par les sociétés
amérindiennes de la côte pacifique de
l'amérique du nord des cérémonies qui
sont basis dans le dos comme la kula
dont j'ai parlé dans une vidéo
précédente le potlatch fait aujourd'hui
partie de ces quelques notions jugé
incontournable pour tout étudiant en
anthropologie
il a été décrit la fin du 19e siècle par
franz boas ns mais c'est l'anthropologue
français marcel mauss qui en a donné
l'analyse la plus complète dans son
essai sur le don tu vois marcel mauss et
reprend les travaux des d'autres je
pense qu'il faudrait vérifier mais je
pense qu'il sait pas il n'a pas voyagé
lui-même donc vraiment c'est quelqu'un
qui va théorisé
qui paraît en 1924 dans sa forme
classique le potlatch consiste en une
distribution cérémoniel très généreuse
de richesse plus précisément il s'agit
d'une fête grandiose au cours de
laquelle un chef de village par exemple
va offrir ostensiblement une certaine
quantité de biens précieux le plus
souvent un rival souvent un autre chef
en vue de le défier il s'agit donc d'un
échange compétitif dans lequel les
adversaires s'engage dans une lutte de
rivalité mais à la différence d'un
combat classique qui se déroulerait avec
des armes les adversaires se battent ici
à coups de cadeaux à coups de dons et de
contre dont le potlatch repose sur
l'idée générale selon laquelle celui qui
donne est supérieur à celui qui reçoit
plus on donne est donc plus on manifeste
ainsi de mépris pour la richesse plus on
acquiert du prestige en donnant son
avoir on acquiert de lettres en offrant
autre prend l'ascendant sur celui qui
reçoit alors tu pourrais dire ouais mais
ce n'est pas vraiment du don parce que
en fait ils vont sacrifier en quelque
sorte des marchandises donné mais c'est
quand même pour obtenir quelque chose et
finalement on a un petit peu comme dans
dubourdieu tu vois où il n'y a pas que
du capital économique du capital
matériel il ya d'autres types de
capitaux et donc il ici on ne serait
autre que dans un cas de valorisation
mais ce que va dire marcel mauss c'est
que l'important c'est qu'ils aient un
côté différé comme dans la cula sais que
c'est pas maintenant que tu vas contre
balancer ça ou que tu veux avoir le
prestige quoi donc il ya toujours un
côté différé
dans le potlatch en donnons on va donc
tout mines et posséder en quelque sorte
son rival
dans ces cérémonies de distribution de
richesse
marcel mauss distingue trois obligations
qui sont à séparables
dans un premier temps alors ça c'est
important parce que dans le bouquin
c'est vraiment une section un chef qui
veut par exemple affirmé ou conserver
son autorité ou encore affiché sa
supériorité sur un rival doit donner
celui qui ne donnerait pas manifesterait
par là son incapacité à diriger le
groupe ou tout simplement son
infériorité
alors que doit-il donner et bien tout ce
qui est précieux tout ce qui a de la
valeur
par exemple des bijoux des armes des
couvertures des terres du bétail ou de
la nourriture
dans un deuxième temps et du point de
vue de celui qui reçoit
refusé le potlatch n'est pas
envisageable car ce serait montrer qu'on
a peur de devoir ensuite rentrer car il
va falloir rendre c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir un certain moment effectuer un
con tre d'eau
refuser un don ce serait avouer qu'on
ait vaincu d'avancé ce serait
reconnaître son infériorité
donc tout ça pour bien montrer que en
fait le côté
utilitariste de notre pensée où
tu vas toujours essayer de maximiser ton
propre profit en tout cas matériel qu'il
est vraiment si tu es socialement et
historiquement parce que dans ces
sociétés là
le marché était totalement différent et
donc s'ils avaient un marché où des
échanges
de marchandises c'était sous d'autres
rapports avec surtout d'autres
dimensions où il ya une dimension
spirituelle beaucoup plus grande mais ça
on le reverra quand je reviendrai sur la
lecture ça va celui qui reçoit a donc
toujours l'obligation morale d'accepter
le don c'est la raison pour laquelle le
don est toujours consenti et qu'il est
même apprécié à haute voix même s'il
constitue en quelque sorte un cadeau
empoisonné et qu'on sait très bien qu'on
aura les pires difficultés à effectuer
ensuite un contre d'eau
dans un troisième temps enfin celui qui
a reçu va donc devoir organiser lui
aussi un potlatch au cours duquel il
effectuera lui même un contre dos car
puisqu'il a accepté le don initial il a
accepté le défi qui lui a été lancée et
il s'est donc engagé dans cette lutte de
rivalité
l'obligation de réaliser un contre don
c'est à dire l'obligation de répondre ou
donc que l'on a reçu l'obligation de
répondre aux défis qui était lancée et
absolue le principe du potlatch est donc
celui de la réciprocité
après le don vient le contre don et
comme c'était aussi le cas avec la kula
il s'agit d'un système basé sur une
réciprocité différé le contre don
intervenant quelques temps après le dos
mais si l'individu qui doit effectuer un
contre dont ne veut pas être humilié
s'il ne veut pas perdre cette guerre des
cadeaux il va devoir faire en sorte que
le contre don qu'il offre en retour soit
plus généreux que le don qu'il avait
reçu autrement dit le principe veut
qu'on doit toujours faire mieux que son
rival on doit toujours se montrer plus
généreux que lui le potlatch est donc un
processus qui est placée sous le signe
de la rivalité il faut systématiquement
dépassé les dons précéderont et le
processus peut durer ainsi un certain
temps le receveur devenant à son tour
d'honneur est le donneur devenant
receveur
mais alors quand s'arrête dont m on
savait que le mardi les vidéos par le
mardi avant c'était le jeudi ou le
mercredi mais les vidéos de semaine sont
beaucoup plus engagés sont beaucoup plus
portés sur de la philosophie est moins
sûr des sciences sociales scientifiques
entre guillemets
mais je me parce que bon moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est quand même de montrer
que le marché au final une logique
mortifère
mais je me demande si le dans ces
sociétés là quelque chose que le
potlatch où finalement il ya quand même
une surenchère tu sais comme dans nos
sociétés où finalement par la logique
même du marché par la logique de
l'argent et du capitalisme tu es
toujours amené à vouloir plus
et bien dans ces sociétés là c'est un
peu la même chose dont le truc est
beaucoup plus collectif beaucoup plus
vaste
en termes
religieux spirituel voilà c'est le mot
que j'ai cherché mais finalement tu
arrive quand même à sacrifier toutes tes
ressources quoi donc tu es quand même
alors après tu te demandes mais est-ce
que anthropologiquement parlant l'homme
est fait pour pour gaspiller quelque
part pour ruiner sont son environnement
enfin c'est la question que je me pose
avec ses lectures
tout simplement quand la réciprocité
cesse c'est à dire quand l'un des
protagonistes ne peut plus répondre à la
demande quand l'un des adversaires n'est
plus en mesure d'effectuer un don qui
soit supérieur à celui qu'il a reçus
quand c'est le cas c'est le dernier
donateurs qui obtient le pouvoir la
domination le prestige les zonards
qu'advient-il alors de celui qui n'a pas
pu rendre le potlatch celui qui n'a pas
eu les moyens de la réciprocité
dans le meilleur des cas il perd son
honneur mais au pire il peut perdre son
rang d'homme libre et devenir alors
l'esclave du donateur d'une certaine
façon comme pour payer sa dette le
potlatch peut aussi se présenter sous
une forme moins classique et consistait
en une distribution où une destruction
spectaculaire de biens précieux
un very louis désolait j'ai peut-être un
petit peu anticipé en disant qu'ils
avaient destruction mais en effet le
potache est aussi un côté destruction
moi ça me fait penser aussi vous savez
par exemple bill gates qui va donner
x x millions d'euros pour telle cause
ces fondations américaines c'est très
américain le système de fondations quand
tu es un milliardaire tu donnes à des
oeuvres caritatives ça ressemble un peu
à ça finalement parce que voilà tu
gaspilles entre guillemets ta fortune
pour la convertir en prestige social
et il ya peut-être une course alors il
faudrait regarder peut-être que des
études existent là dessus une course
entre celui qui aura la fondation et les
dons les plus généreux
mais voilà c'est c'est encore présents
alors marcel mauss évidemment ne pas
parler de bill gates ça serait un
anachronisme mais ils essaient après de
montrer en quoi des logiques comme
celles là sont encore présentes dans nos
sociétés à nous c'est à dire que pour
lui
nos sociétés sont plus loin dans la
division du travail et dans
dans le rapport dans l'évolution du
rapport marchand il dit mais voilà ça ce
sont des formes qui existe toujours dans
certaines strates de notre société mais
qui sont tendance à évoluer
j'aime bien cette idée là que les choses
évoluent très lentement et que il ya
toujours des choses et qui a pas
forcément tu vois maintenant une société
capitaliste
et puis avant une société moyen-âgeuse
que en fait tant tu maintiens des chose
d'ancien régime dans le nouveau régime
enfin voila c'est très très marxien pour
le coup je trouve
et il faudrait chercher est ce que est
ce que marcel moreau moss a lu marx
parce que je vois vraiment des liens
mais le problème c'est que je vois des
liens dans tout en fait donc jours c'est
un problème
qui table gaspillage ostentatoire dont
le but est de prouver sa supériorité
morale par un apparent on retrouve aussi
ses gaspillages dans
de fête folklorique 1 quand tu vois la
tomatina en italie je pense on peut
regarder des images après
avoir un petit peu quelles sont les
modalités je connais juste un peu les
images la tomatina mais il ya un immense
gaspillage de ressources mais c'est
aussi la même chose chez nous enfin chez
nous en belgique salut les accule pas tu
vas bien ce fait longtemps
alors coucou tout le monde je ne sais
pas s'il ya grand monde aujourd'hui sur
le stream donc en fait aujourd'hui
on essaie de d'explorer laissé sur le
don de marcel mauss et si je parlais du
jeu montre des vidéos sur la cula et le
potlatch qui sont vraiment des choses
essentielles en anthropologie et dont
marcel mauss va analyser et donc j'en
étais sûr le les gaspillages de
ressources puisque le potlatch
finalement chaque tribu va va gaspiller
parfois on va sacrifier va détruire des
biens précieux alors il était question
je pense de cuivre notamment
doré mais est-ce que chez nous dans nos
sociétés on a ça je pensais la tomatina
ah bah ça c'est super alors si tu as vu
le postérieur je me pose parfois des
questions est ce que est ce que des gens
le voient est-ce que ça sert donc je
lance des bouteilles à la mer et puis
ben c'est bien si tu as trouvé la
bouteille est le message qui était
dedans super merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'être là et donc je disais la tomatina
mais en belgique il ya le carnaval de
binche dans lequel les gilles vont
distribuer des oranges donc on jette des
oranges montrera des images après
et parfois c'est orange vont être
gaspillé quoi parce que moment il des
gets partout mais il ya un côté parce
que ma femme a été
distributrice d'orange donc elle était
dans le camion où il ya toutes les
oranje pour me remplir des paniers de
gilles parent d'un chemin dans un autre
carnaval similaires et donc il ya
vraiment un jeu une lutte d'influencé
pour à celui qui aura lancé le plus
d'orange et donc on retrouve un petit
peu ce côté là que celui qui donne le
plus bas c'est celui qui va retirer le
plus de prestige et de capital
symbolique ne dirai bourdieu de
l'événement 1 parce que pour rappel pour
marcel mauss il reste toujours dans nos
sociétés dites modernes des dans
certaines strates des éléments de
rapports antérieurs
qui ne disparaissent pas tout de suite
forcément sans doute qu'aujourd'hui
c'est plus difficile qu'à l'époque de
marcel mauss d'observer ça puisque nos
sociétés évoluent très vite
mais je pense que voilà les certains
moments folkloriques ou encore des
brides des bribes de ce peuple atx de
quelque chose qui ressemblerait à 5
ans désintérêt vis-à-vis de tout ce qui
est matériel à nouveau le principe ici
sera que plus en manifestent ainsi de
mépris pour la richesse pour les biens
précieux plus en acquiert du prestige et
du pouvoir social par exemple un chef
désireux de maintenir son statut aux
yeux de ses subordonnés et peut ainsi
organisé une cérémonie grandiose au
cours de laquelle il procédera soit à la
destruction de ses propres biens soit à
la redistribution de ceux ci à
l'ensemble des habitants de son village
dans les deux cas il aura ainsi affiché
par sa générosité et son mépris apparent
de la richesse et des possessions sa
supériorité et sa capacité à conserver
son statut
quelle que soit la forme qu'il prenne le
potlatch en tout cas pour objectif de
préserver ou d'augmenter le prestige et
le pouvoir social d'un individu ayant un
statut important
je vous remercie d'avoir regardé écouté
cette courte vidéo et jeux mais merci
alain bas je mets donc abonnez-vous à sa
chaîne ainsi les sciences sociales vous
intéresse parce que c'est assez bien
faire j'aime bien ces vidéos sont très
synthétique alors on parlait de la
tomatina si vous ne connaissez pas la
tomatina et puis on ira peut-être voir
thomas
tina 1ère a peut-être voir sur sur
wikipédia
les modalités parce que j'aimerais
savoir est ce qu'il ya une concurrence
dans le gaspillage quelque part parce
que c'est ça qui nous intéresse la
petite vidéo du parisien josé passages
improvisés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cancer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon épouse m'avait dit un truc comme
quoi il fallait justement mettre des
lunettes pour quoi que ça l'acidité de
la tomate truc j'ai vu ses lunettes mais
il faut faire un certains trucs pour
éviter d'avoir des problèmes après avec
l'automate
[Musique]
et
problématique
[Musique]
parce que dénoncer le cas
plus
bon
ayew j
ap
mais
ouais mais ça existait avant aussi avant
le coc vide on va les voir après sur
wikipédia si on n'a pas plus
d'informations en vitesse
mais c'est justement ça que je trouve
que j'associe oppose match puisque voilà
danser dans ces sociétés là tu va
gaspiller juste pour du prestige ou pour
autre chose que simplement le côté
utilitariste ou et donc c'est pour ça
que je trouve que on est sûr sur un
rapport
qui peut être
analogue
[Musique]
m
oui bon dans ce contexte actuel c'est
complètement dingue ça ça c'est sûr mais
on va regarder
tomatina
sur wikipédia ici
il existe plusieurs versions de
l'origine de cette fête la version la
plus court en 1945 ce qu'on a entendu
[Musique]
savoir s'il ya
mais là il n'y a pas forcément à côté de
celui qui en jettera le plus quoi la
vraie règle à la fête commence à 11h
non
alors moi ça me fait penser aussi le
potlatch au carnaval de binche
nous allons tuer avant de défiler au
champagne il efface les inégalités
ça fait partie du sport alors appelé la
tâche et les binchois de très généreux
encore la muse il ya du potlatch parce
qu'en fait chaque gilles déjà doit faire
une cagnotte assez importante je crois
que ça coûte plus de 2000 euros pour
pour avoir le costume et tout ça mais en
plus voilà tu reçois tous les deals
vue gorbatchev aubin pas de chance je
pense qu'il n'est pas décédé dans bad
chef
merci pour le follow alors
je disais le gilet reçoit tous les
gilles du ramassage et là on donne ainsi
au champagne les huîtres machin des
choses voilà qui ont une certaine valeur
et
tu donnes tu donnes tu donnes donc on
est vraiment sûr du potlatch et après tu
vas voir les oranges que tu vas lancé au
public et a même du gaspillage mais
l'important c'est de donner le maximum
donc je trouve que on est vraiment sur
une sorte de potlatch ou mécanique qu'on
retrouve dans le potlatch
gens bien voulu vous montrer avec les
faits le carnaval d'alost où parfait des
polémiques parce qu'ils font des chaires
un peu spéciaux mais regardez gilles
gilles orange
lacq orthez
[Musique]
alors c'était mon sosie au le merci à
toi pour ton contenu mais ça avec
plaisir je pense on va s'entraîner
pendant quelques soirées bas super alors
il ya deux rendez-vous semaine le
dimanche soir où là on en lit un article
de sciences sociales on est plus
d'objectif parce que le mardi en fait
voilà au lider ont fait des lectures de
classiques des sciences sociales mais
bon on n'hésite pas un petit peu à
prendre partie être un peu plus dans
l'idéologie est donc ici aujourd'hui je
lisais
occupé à découvrir marcel mauss et son
essai sur le don donc on a vu tous les
prérequis pour combien comprendre ce
qu'il veut nous dire et moi je pense que
marcel mauss lui-même est un pré requis
à une bonne lecture de marx alors c'est
peu c'est un peu un anachronisme mais
quand tu veux lire
le premier chapitre du capital je pense
que pour bien comprendre
pour bien intégrer toute la puissance du
propos de marx
moss c'est vraiment bien voilà ça c'est
un peu c'est un peu l'idée
à
leur jeu marcel mauss dit que si je sais
pas si
les deux joueurs qui sont là
actuellement vous étiez là tout à
l'heure mais marcel mauss nous dit que
le potlatch qui est quelque chose qui se
faisait en amérique du nord et quelques
shows est un fait social total parce
qu'il va mobiliser toutes les catégories
de la population dans différentes
demandes dimension mais tu vois ici le
carnaval de binche pour moi ce sont des
choses aussi qui peuvent être
considérées dans nos sociétés le
carnaval de binche ou des folklores
équivalent comme des faits sociaux
totaux parce que toutes les catégories
de la population sont mobilisés tu vois
ici notamment les enfants mais aussi
dans différentes dimensions que ce soit
au niveau familial
bon peut-être pas le carnaval de binche
quoique sicile carnaval de binche c'est
aussi parce que c'est fait sur base du
calendrier religieux
chrétiens donc il ya aussi une dimension
religieuse il ya une dimension
esthétique
il ya une dimension
[Musique]
juridique parce qu'on va changer les
plans de circulation les règlements
voilà il ya des effectifs de police donc
je pense que on est sur quelque chose
qui pourrait être
analysés de manière pertinente avec
marcel mauss
quand tu parles sur une vidéo en cours
de lecture en entendant plus mais là
j'ai arrêté la vidéo
c'est peut-être avant désolé en tout cas
[Musique]
voilà du coup si quelqu un quelque chose
vous a échappé
n'hésitez pas à poser la question donc
voilà je sais pas ce que ce que je n'ai
pas dit du coup ou ce que vous n'avez
pas entendu du coup voilà mais pour moi
voilà carnaval des choses comme ça ça
peut être considéré à mon sens comme des
faits sociaux toto et aussi comme des
mécanismes proches de ceux du potlatch
où tu donnes et finalement c'est pas la
générosité c'est ça qui est important
c'est que le plus gros le meilleur
d'honneur sera celui qui récoltera le
plus de prestige social
voilà
donc ça c'est le carnaval de binche
bien on va revenir à notre lecture du
coup
dans son josemi vous reprendrez
différentes vidéos si vous arrivez en
cours de ce crime ou si vous être sur le
replay alors webcam voilà on revient là
est donc là je vais reprendre la lecture
les différents éléments qui me semble
intéressant par rapport à ça
alors un certain alan
moss par deux c'est de ces peuples
qu'ils considèrent comme premier et
ensuite il va aussi essayer de voir
comment ça évolue et dans des sociétés
autres que la société européenne
et où est-ce qu'on retrouve des éléments
de ce potlatch ou dans nos sociétés et
pré moderne
et donc j'ai pas tout je vais pas tout
lire évidemment
voilà ici je vais relire je reviens en a
un petit peu en arrière là marcel mauss
et sur le potlatch et nous dit car le
potlatch est bien plus qu'un phénomène
juridique il est un de ceux que nous
proposons d'appeler totaux il est
religieux mythologique
chamanistes hic puisque les chefs six
ans qui s'y engagent y représenter
incarne les ancêtres les dieux dont il
porte le nom dont ils dansent des danses
et dont les esprits les possèdent il est
économique il faut mesurer la valeur
l'importance les raisons et les effets
de cette transaction énorme même
actuellement quand les chiffres en
valeur européenne le potache est aussi
un phénomène de morphologie sociale les
réunions des tribus des clans et des
familles
même celles des nations y produit
nervosité une excitation remarquable on
fraternise est cependant on reste
étranger exactement comme dans un
carnaval
on communique et on s'oppose dans un
gigantesque commerce est inconstant
tournoi nous passons sur les phénomènes
esthétique qui sont extrêmement nombreux
enfin même au point de vue juridique en
plus de ce qu'on a déjà dégagé de la
forme de ces contrats et de ce que l'on
pourrait appeler l'objet humain du
contrat en plus du statut juridique des
contractants il faut ajouter ceux ci les
objets matériels des contrats les choses
qui sont échangés ont elles aussi une
vertu spécial qui fait qu'on les donne
et surtout qu'on les ronds donc tu as un
truc qui est très puissant et qui
pénètre vraiment dans tout dans tout les
interstices de la société
et du collectif alors ici mos propose
une première conclusion et qui est
importante parce que c'est celle qui
m'intéresse finalement
et je vous propose aujourd'hui pour des
lectures ultérieure ce principe de l'
échange dont a dû être celui des
sociétés qui ont dépassé la phase de la
prestation totale et qui cependant ne
sont pas encore parvenues aux contrats
individuels purs impôts pour beauce le
contrat individuel pur c'est la forme
moderne finalement de l' échange de
biens ou marché où roulent l'argent à la
vente proprement dit et surtout à la
notion de prix estimées en monnaie peser
et titre est donc pour lui c'est
vraiment un côté évolutif c'est ce que
j'expliquais tout à l'heure et je trouve
que c'est très pour le coup marc st
alors voilà dans le chapitre iii pour
rappel j'ai mis le lien vers le pdf au
début du chat
est donc au début du chapitre iii il va
déjà rappeler certaines choses et puis
après il va faire cette analyse un peu
comparé que j'expliquais il ya quelques
instants tous les faits précédents ont
été recueillis dans ce domaine qu'on
appelle celui de l'ethnographie donc la
cula le potlatch tout ça
de plus ils sont localisés dans cete qui
peuplent les bords du pacifique
on se sert d'ordinaire de ce genre de
fait à titre de curiosité ou à la
rigueur de comparaison pour mesurer
combien nos sociétés ces cartes ou se
rapprochent de ce genre d'institution
qu'on appelle primitive et c'est vrai
que c'est toujours intéressant
l'ethnographie d'un recours aux travaux
de nos graphiques pour prendre en compte
et fracassé j'ai envie de dire nos
représentations pour considérer que ce
que nous vivons n'est pas des jeunes eux
sont essentiellement pas des choses
naturelles mais sont des constructions
sociales
moi c'est avec ça que j'attaque
avec les élèves qui débutent les
sciences sociales les rapports homme
femme tu montres des tribus comme les
mots ceux qui sont des tribus j'ai
besoin de dire d ethnie en chine je
pense qu'ils ont fait le rôle du père
totalement effacée puisque le père est
absent et c'est l'oncle des enfants qui
va jouer un rôle avec la mer mais la
mère a elle même un rôle qui dans nos
sociétés seraient considérés comme très
masculin puisque c'est la mère qui a
tout une fonction ou un rôle de
production et donc voila tu vois prendre
ce qui se passe dans une autre culture
que la nôtre c'est très intéressant pour
venir fracassé finalement les les
habitudes et les pratiques que nous
avons et que nous considérons comme
naturelle et comme non construites
socialement aussi les prendre ce qui se
passe dans le temps ça peut être aussi
intéressant
cependant ils ont une valeur
sociologique général donc moss va plus
loin il dit c'est pas juste pour avoir
du contraste qu'on va voir ses travaux à
nos graphiques c'est vraiment pour en
retirer des formes sociologique qui vont
être utiles pour analyser notre propre
société c'est ce que j'explique depuis
tout à l'heure en disant que dans nos
sociétés il ya des formes proches du
potlatch de l'aquila qui peuvent être
tirés ou en tout cas des éléments de ces
pratiques là qui peuvent être retirés
cependant ils ont une valeur
sociologique général puisqu'il nous
permettent de comprendre à un moment de
l'évolution sociale
mais il ya plus ils ont encore une
portée en histoire sociale des
institutions de ce type ont réellement
fournis la transition vers le forme ne
forment à nous de droit et d'économie
elles peuvent servir à expliquer
historiquement nos propres sociétés
voilà ça c'est vraiment ce qui est
intéressant si tu veux après faire une
analyse marxiste
alors ici j'avais surligner rapidement
quelques passages où moss va justement
dans des sociétés pré moderne mais en
europe ou dans d'autres régions du monde
la civilisation germanique elle aussi à
londres a été longtemps sans marcher
donc encore une fois un moss veut
montrer que le marché n'est pas la seule
forme de lien social que nous pouvons en
voir quand il s'agit d'échanger
la civilisation germanique elle aussi a
été longtemps son marché elle était
restée essentiellement féodal et
paysannes chez elle la notion et même
les mots de prix d'achats et de ventes
semblent d'origine récente
plus anciennement elle avait développé
extrêmement tout le système du potlatch
mais surtout tout le système des dons
voilà par exemple lors du baptême des
communions des fiançailles du mariage
les invités ils comprennent souvent tout
le village après le repas de noces par
exemple le jour précédent ou le jour
suivant présente des cadeaux de noces
dont la valeur généralement dépasse de
beaucoup les frais de noces voilà une
chose qu'on retrouve aussi
de par chez nous j'ai envie de dire
après ça dépend si vous habitez aussi
dans des tissus ou si vous vivez dans
des tissus
plus traditionnels ou voilà si vous êtes
si tu as un pari bon ben vous êtes
peut-être moins dans des dents des
solidarités de ce type
mais voilà c'est peut-être une
représentation en congés
dans le droit chinois enfin une grande
civilisation la chinoise a gardé de 7
ans archaïque précisément le principe de
droit qui nous intéresse elle reconnaît
le lien insoluble de toute chose avec
l'original propriétaire même aujourd'hui
un individu qui a vendu un de ses biens
même meuble garde toute sa vie durant
contre l'acheteur une sorte de droit de
pleurer entre guillemets c'est bien
le père hoang a consigné des modèles de
ces billets de gémissements que remet le
vendeur acheteur est carrément c'est une
espèce de droit de suite sur la chose
donc tu as vendu la chose mettez un
droit de suite un droit de regard sur ce
qui se passe sur cette chose mais les un
droit de suite sur la personne
et qui poursuit le vendeur même bien
longtemps après que la chaussette entrer
définitivement dans d'autres patrimoine
et après que tous les termes du contrat
irrévocable ou été exécutés
par la chose transmise même si elle est
fongible l'alliance qui a été contracté
n'est pas momentanée et les contraintes
contractants sont censés en perpétuelle
dépendance aux congés c'est quelque
chose qui est consommable donc même des
trucs consommables tu guerre d'un droit
là dessus moi ça me fait toujours penser
à tolkien et aux elfes qui quand ils ont
formé forget quelque chose en garde une
certaine propriété ça leur appartient
toujours
et donc ça nous permet de relativiser
nos rapports marchands alors je vais
juste coupé le stream une petite minute
je vais en profiter pour lancer une pub
parce que là j'ai une odeur
insupportable qui vient de brûler donc
je vais vérifier qui a pas de problème a
tout de suite
si la pub est fini ou pas parce que je
lance rarement des pubs mais là ça m'a
permis d'aller voir la fenêtre ce qui se
passait j'ai vu qu'il ya de l'orage pas
loin mais en tout cas je vois rien qui
fait de la fumée ou des choses comme ça
mais j'ai le voisin qui parfois brûlent
des choses sur son terrain
et des choses pas très nettes en tout
cas
voilà alors ici je vois par manque la
pub est fini je sais pas si c'est fini
j'espère que c'est fini je continue
alors ici on est dans la conclusion
c'est sans doute ce qui est plus
intéressant
il est possible d'étendre ses
observations à nos propres sociétés ou
quoi oui parce que c'est le transfert
qui nous intéresse une partie
considérable de notre morale et de notre
vie elle-même stationnent toujours dans
cette même atmosphère du don de
l'obligation et de la liberté mêlée
heureusement tout n'est pas encore
classé exclusivement en termes d'achat
et de vente parce que c'est ce que veut
montrer moss c'est que notre société
évolue vers de l'achat et de la vente
dont divers des rapports marchands et
commerciaux 1 tu peux pas lui donner
tort parce que quand tu vois que même
aujourd'hui le fait de s'occuper de ses
enfants de tes parents qui sont âgés
voilà maintenant c'est devenu un marché
aussi
donc des choses vraiment très liées à
cers domestique c'est vraiment devenu un
marché bon ton ménage c'est un marché
sauf si tu le fais toi même évidemment
pourquoi d'autres quand tu vois que la
poste un certain moment faisait facturer
le fait que le facteur s'arrête chez toi
ou chez sa grand-mère pour discuter un
petit un petit peu bon voilà
mais il nous dit ça n'empêche que on a
toujours
des rapports
basés sur le don dans nos sociétés nous
n'avons pas qu'une morale de marchands
il nous reste des gens et des classes
qui ont encore les moeurs d'autrefois et
nous nous y plier ont presque tous au
moins à certaines époques de l'année ou
à certaines occasions c'est ce que j'ai
essayé aussi de vous montrer avec ces
exemples de folklore dans lesquelles le
don reprend vigueur le folklore ou de
tradition
il faut rendre plus qu'on a reçu la
tournée est toujours plus chère et plus
grande ainsi telle famille villageoise
de notre enfance en lorraine
moss vient de l'est comme dur came
d'ailleurs ils étaient famille ensemble
une très belle photo que j'avais partagé
sur instagram dans lequel vous les voyez
dans la maison familiale demos
ainsi telle famille villageoise de notre
enfance en lorraine qui se restreignent
à la vie la plus modeste en temps
courant se ruiner pour ses hôtes à
l'occasion des fêtes patronales de
mariage de communion ou d'enterrement il
faut être grand seigneur entre
guillemets dans ces occasions on peut
même dire qu'une partie de notre peuple
se conduit ainsi constamment et
dépensent sans compter quand il s'agit
de ses hôtes de ces fêtes de ses
étrennes et c'est vrai que si tu
retrouves des éléments du don c'est
vraiment au moment de fête qu'ils soient
folkloriques ou familiaux
l'invitation doit être fait et elle doit
être acceptée imagine quand tu invites
que tes parents tu invites pour leur
anniversaire de mariage et qui disent
non je vais pas quoi on imagine bien que
les relations familiales vont un petit
peu en pâtir nous avons encore cet usage
même dans nos corporation libéral de ne
veux pas ça c'est vraiment des deux
fragments je trouve intéressant de nos
jours les vieux principe réagissent
contre les rigueurs les abstractions et
lésiné inhumanité de notre code
il a fallu longtemps pour reconnaître la
propriété artistique littéraire
scientifique au delà de l'acte brutale
de la vente du manuscrit de la première
machine ou de l'oeuvre d'art originale
donc ici moss en nous parlant du droit
d'auteur nous montre où nous prouve que
il n'ya pas que les échanges marchands
matériel qui vaille est que un échange
immatériel peut être aussi consenti en
même temps que la vente de l'objet quand
tu vends voilà ton manuscrit il ya des
droits d'auteur qui vont être
transférable donc quand on avait ce que
j'expliquais en chine où chaque vendeur
garde un droit finalement de regard sur
les produits qu'il a vendu bien en fait
chez nous il ya aussi un peu de ça dans
le droit d'autres et c'est ce qui
explique mosquée dans la cantine
most of books
à plusieurs reprises on a vu combien
toute cette économie de l' échange dont
était loin de rentrer dans les cadres de
l'autonomie soit disant naturel de
l'utilitarisme nom qui serait notre
économie actuelle la notion de valeur
fonctionne dans cette société des
surplus très grand absolument parlant
sont amassés ils sont dépensés souvent
en pure perte avec un luxe relativement
énorme et qui n'est rien qui n'a rien de
mercantile
des signes de richesse des sortes de
monnaies qui sont échangés mais toute
cette économie très riche est encore
plein d'éléments religieux la monnaie a
encore son pouvoir magique est encore
lié au clan ou à l'individu les divers
activités économiques par exemple
marchés sont imprégnés de rites et de
mythes tout ça pour dire que tu vas
souvent avoir des libéraux qui vont me
dire oui mais dont dans toute société il
ya eu des échanges marchands il ya eu du
marché et c'est pas faux mais c'était
vraiment plus anecdotique et il y avait
bien d'autres choses avec cet échange
marchand c'est ce que nous rappelle moss
ici
c'est bien autre chose que de l'utile
qui circulent dans ces sociétés de
toujours la plupart déjà assez éclairé
les clans les âges et généralement les
sexes à cause des multiples rapports
auxquels les contacts donne lieu sont
dans un état de perpétuelle
effervescence économique et cette
excitation et elle-même fort peu terre à
terre elle est bien moins prosaïque que
nos ventes et achats que nous louage de
service et que nos jeux de bourse
très intéressant mais moi je vois que
dure que marc sound en fait
les termes que nous avons en tout cas où
la première par le premier chapitre du
capital les termes que nous avons
employé présent cadeau dont ne sont pas
eux-mêmes tout à fait exact nous n'en
trouvons pas d'autre voilà tout ne crée
toujours la barrière du langage ou tu
penses avec ton langage mais ton langage
que contraint et contrainte à penser
c'est un facteur limitant en fait le
langage ou non un sou
un esquimau europe d'une trentaine de
mots pour décrire la neige parce que il
en a l'usagé nous on aura qu'un seul mot
est donc on est beaucoup plus limité
pour exprimer les nuances de ce qu'est
la neige voilà c'est transposable tout
objet
au fond d'eux-mêmes que ces dons ne sont
pas libres ils ne sont pas réellement
désintéressée ce sont déjà des contres
prestations pour la plupart-- et fait
même en vue non seulement de payer des
services et des choses mais aussi de
maintenir une alliance profitable et qui
te le peut même être refusé donc on
n'est pas sur des rapports des
intéressés c'est pas ça que dit moss
dans le don
il ya de l'intérêt mais qui est pas un
intérêt foncièrement matériel et et
utilitaires
même la destruction pure de richesse ne
correspond pas à ce détachement complet
on croirait y trouver puisque ils font
ça pour le prestige
faudrait voir si bourdieu allume hausse
mais le motif de ces dons et de ses
consommation forcenée de ses pertes et
de ces destructions folle de richesse
n'est à aucun degré surtout dans les
sociétés a pas de l'ach désintéressé
entre chefs et vassaux entre vassaux
étonnant par ses dons ses la hiérarchie
qui s'établit données s'est manifesté sa
supériorité
être plus plu au magistère accepté sans
rendre ou sans rendre plus c'est ce
subordonné devenir client et serviteurs
devenir petit choix plus bas dans ces
civilisations on est intéressé mais
d'autres façons que de notre temps on
théorise mais pour dépenser
d'autre part en échange mais ce sont
surtout des choses de luxe des ornements
des vêtements ou ce sont des choses
immédiatement consommée des festins on
rend avec l'usure avec intérêt mais
c'est pour humilier le premier donateur
ou échangiste et non pas seulement pour
le récompenser de là certes que lui
cause une consommation différée parce
que pour rappel moss nous dit que le don
il ya forcément un côté différent tu
rends pas tout de suite ce qu'on t'a
donné où tu ne rêves offre pas un cadeau
tout de suite si on offre un cadeau pour
ton anniversaire tu attends
l'anniversaire de la personne qui te l'a
offert pour lui en donner un
entre l'économie relativement amorphe et
désintéressé à l'intérieur de ce groupe
i règle la vie des clans centralien ou
américains du nord
d'une part et l'économie individuelle
est du pur intérêt que nos sociétés ont
connu au moins en partie dès qu'elle fut
trouvée par les populations c'est
mythique et grecs d'autre part entre ces
deux types dis-je
ses étages et toute une série immense
d'institutions et d'événements
économiques
et cette série n'est pas gouvernée par
le rationalisme économique dont on fait
si vous lanciez la théorie donc je pense
que moscou en partie vraiment contre une
vision purement libérale de la société
en dix ans mais déjà notre société elle
même ne donne des exemples
de comportements non libéraux quelque
part
le mot même d'intérêt et récent
d'origine technique comptable interest
latin qu'on écrivait sur les livres de
compte on fasse des rentes apercevoir
dans les morales ancien les plus
épicurienne c'est le bien le plaisir
qu'on recherche et non pas
matérielle utilité il a fallu la
victoire du rationalisme et du
mercantilisme
pour que soit mise en vigueur est élevé
à la hauteur de principe les notions de
profits et d'individus alors là bon
quand tu verras ce que ce qu'on va
raconter avec la critique de la valeur
là c'est à l'impression que
les tenants de la critique des valeurs
robert courte et en scène le [ __ ]
pourparlers citée on lui mousse
on peut presque date et le triomphe de
la notion d'intérêt individuel
ce sont nos sociétés d'occident qui ont
très récemment fait de l'homme un animal
économique l'homo economicus devrait-on
dire mais ça s'est il le met pas mais
nous ne sommes pas encore tous des êtres
de ce genre dans nos masses et dans nos
élites la dépense pure et irrationnel et
de pratique courante est là encore
caractéristiques de quelques fossiles de
notre noblesse j'aime bien la
formulation l'homo economicus abbas il
le dit j'ai oublié qu'il le disait n'est
pas derrière nous il est devant nous
comme l'homme de la morale et du devoir
comme l'homme de la science et de la
raison c'est intéressant qu'il lit tout
ça
l'homme a été trop longtemps aient
longtemps autre chose il n'y a pas bien
longtemps qu'il est une machine
compliquée
d'une machine à calculer est vachement
bien dit ce dernier passage les faits
que nous avons étudiés sont tout ce
qu'on nous permettent l'expression des
faits sociaux toto
c'est à dire qu'ils mettent en branle
dans certains cas la totalité de la
société et de ses institutions potlatch
clan affronter tribus se visite en
aidant d'autres cas seulement un très
grand nombre d'institutions en
particulier lorsque ces échanges et ces
contrats concernent plutôt des individus
tous ces phénomènes sont à la fois
juridiques économiques religieux et même
esthétique morphologiques etc ils sont
juridique de droit privé et public de
moralité organisé diffus strictement
obligatoire ou simplement loués blâmait
politique et domestiques en même temps
intéressant les classes sociales aussi
bien que les clans et les familles a
donc tu vois ça vraiment ça pénètre
toute la société et toute la société et
participantes et prend parti à ces
phénomènes
ils sont économiques car l'idée de la
valeur de l'utile de l'intérêt du luxe
de la richesse de l'acquisition de
l'accumulation et d'autre part celle de
la consommation même celle de la dépense
pur purement somptuaires ils sont
partout présentes bien qu'ils y soient
entendus autres manquent aujourd'hui
chez nous
voilà je vais pas lire tout le passage
mais tout le passage est très
intéressant ce sont donc plus que des
thèmes
plus que des éléments d'institutions
plus que des institutions complexe plus
même que des systèmes d'institutions
divisé par exemple en religion droit
économie
ce sont des tous des systèmes sociaux
entiers dont nous avons essayé de
décrire le fonctionnement il y a dans
ses observations concrètes de la vie
sociale le moyen de trouver des faits
nouveaux
que nous commençons seulement entre voir
rien à notre avis n'est plus urgent ni
fructueux que cette étude des faits
sociaux c'est pas nous tu dois le dire à
mon vieux
elle a un double avantage d'abord un
avantage de généralité car ces faits de
fonctionnement général ont des chances
d'être plus universel que les diverses
institutions ou que les divers thèmes de
ces institutions toujours plus ou moins
accidentellement teinté d'une couleur
locale mais surtout elle a un avantage
de réalité on arrive ainsi à voir les
choses sociale elle-même
dans le concret comme elles sont dans
les sociétés ont saisi plus que des
idées ou des règles ont saisi des hommes
des groupes et leurs comportements on
les voit se mouvoir comme en mécanique
on voit des masses et des systèmes où
comme dans la mer nous voyons des
pieuvres des anémones nous apercevons
des nombres d'hommes des forces mobiles
et qui flotte dans leur milieu et dans
leurs sentiments eh bien je vais vous
dire un truc ce passage pour moi c'est
toute la passion que j'ai pour les
sciences sociales c'est exactement ça
c'est c'est incroyable je suis tous les
jours étonné par le social par ces
choses comme les a tout à l'heure on est
étonné par la tomate in her le social
c'est pour moi un objet d'observation
mais infinie et éternel parce que je ne
comprendrai jamais tellement ça mais
alors après quand tu arrive parfois à
déceler des des éléments de cette
mécanique
collective
il y en a vraiment je suis aussi en
extase devant la société que je commence
à comprendre parce qu'à un
joli un auteur je comprends jamais la
société je dis pas que on l'a comprendre
un jour mais que quand tu observes voilà
des animaux ou des choses comme ça quoi
alors les hommes sont voilà c'est pas
exactement la même chose mais
voilà enfin pour moi c'est un passage
qui me touche beaucoup parce que
je me retrouve beaucoup j'espère que
vous aussi que vous y retrouver alors
j'ai surligner un dernier passage
les sociétés ont progressé dans la
mesure
où elles mêmes leur ce groupe et enfin
leur individus ont su stabiliser leur
rapport donner recevoir et enfin rendre
pour commencer il a fallu d'avoir
d'abord savoir poser les lens c'est
alors qu'on a réussi à échanger les
biens et les personnes non plus
seulement de plomb un clan mais deux
tribus attributs et de nation à nation
et surtout d'individu à individu c'est
seulement ensuite que les gens ont su se
créer se satisfaire mutuellement des
intérêts et enfin les défendre sans
avoir à recourir aux armes c'est ainsi
que le clan la tribu les peuples ont su
et c'est ainsi que demain dans notre
monde dit civilisé les classes et les
nations et aussi les individus doivent
savoir s'opposer sans ce massacre et se
donner sans se sacrifier les uns aux
autres c'est l'un des secrets permanent
de leur sagesse et de leur solidarité et
là marcel mauss parle un autre thème que
je trouve très intéressant en fait quand
tu t'intéresses aux sciences sociales tu
te dis la grande question en tout cas
moi la mienne c'est comment ça se fait
qu'on se tape plus sur la gueule quoi
comment
de par le truchement de des interactions
sociales on a réussi à pacifier en
partie après ça il ya toujours de la
violence évidemment c'était et des
violences qui sont symboliques qui son
mental on est bien d'accord je dis pas
que on vit dans le monde des bisounours
c'est loin d'être ma pensée mais c'est
clair que la violence physique a
vachement diminué même si elles existent
encore dans certaines parties du monde
dès que tu as quelqu'un de sérieux qui
travaillent un historien sérieux qui
travaillent sur la violence tu vois
quand même que la violence
diminuent et c'est sans doute parce que
nous sommes de plus en plus sensibles à
la violence et c'est tant mieux j'ai
envie de dire que la violence nous est
de plus en plus insupportable un thème
développé notamment par laurent
mucchielli et donc si moss nous
débarrasser par tous mais ces mécanismes
du don du contre don qu'on renforce des
solidarités qu'on renforce le lien
social et qu'on peut enfin déposez les
lens voilà
est très chouette finalement bouquin bon
pas forcément à lire mais les est ce que
tu peux retirer de tout ça il ya quand
même des choses et bien sûr connaître la
culotte potlatch c'est quand même des
des bases en anthropologie mais je pense
aussi le fait social total moi c'est un
truc que je vais retour reprendre avec
mes élèves
et puis pour nous notre projet ici de
lecture de classiques de sciences
sociales ça va être une bonne base voilà
alors je sais pas si vous avez des
questions je vois que il ya quand même
quelques quelques personnes sur le
stream et je vous remercie d'être là ce
que vous avez des questions pas si vous
n'avez pas de question je vais je vais
arrêter parce que moi j'ai eu fini
mon taf j'ai envie de dire
la semaine prochaine je sais pas encore
trop ce qu'on va lire
mais un truc voilà qui va nous permettre
de continuer notre progression je ne
sais pas si on attaquera directement dur
came
directement marx mais on pourrait lire
aussi dur km
sur le fait social
ou alors on attaquera directement le
chapitre 1 du capital
il ya un truc que je voulais dire mais
j'ai oublié comme d'hab
y'a trop de penser en même temps
oui et un truc que je voulais dire je
reviens dessus ce que je trouve aussi
c'est que à certains moments marcel
mauss il est très fort dans le normatif
alors évidemment c'est un peu aussi jugé
quelque chose d'il ya cent ans presque
avec les yeux 26 presque s'entend
puisque c'est
avec nos vieux d'aujourd'hui on avait un
accord mais ça ça me pose un problème et
instruments ils dit vraiment voilà ce
vers quoi la société devrait aller moi
je trouve que quand on fait des sciences
sociales en tout cas
on doit pas tomber dans ce bella après
quand tu fais la philosophie politique
quand tu es l'idéologie on est bien
d'accord que ce qu'on fait un peu ici
quoi il ya un peu une direction mais je
trouve que parfois ça se ressent dans le
bouquin bon et bien voilà ben jeunes
gens ou
personnes plus âgées aux joueurs que j
jeunes gens et bien merci d'avoir
participé à ce stream merci à tous ceux
et toutes celles qui ont participé
au chat phoenix évidemment fidèle parmi
les fidèles léa aussi
fidèle de la chaîne merci à gorbatchev
pour
sa première venue et son follow et je
vous dis à dimanche prochain on lire un
article de science sociale or je crois
que je vais l'imposer et je peux déjà
vous montrer de quoi on parlera
parce que la semaine dernière je vais
proposer au vote les différents articles
qu'on pouvait lire le dimanche et on n'a
pas choisi celui que j'aurais bien voulu
qu'on lise après tout c'est quand même
moi qui anime la chaîne donc je peux
quand même imposer certaines choses et
donc on va lire cet article parce que je
pense qui peut être réellement utile est
ici avait un article je vais vous
montrer ça avec la vue
ici
donc l'article est un article d'adrien
paix bourdy qui est à l'école des chefs
formation professionnelle en lycée
hôtelier pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans
l'hôtellerie et la restauration
et donc l'abstract ici me semble super
intéressant et ça me semble super
intéressant parce que moi je vais
commencer avec la réplique de macron
quand il dit ouais t'as qu'à traverser
la rue et il ya le reste ou d'en face
qui en qui engage ou des choses comme ça
quoi mais c'est super intéressant parce
qu'on va voir que évidemment c'est plus
compliqué que ça et que si il manque du
personnel c'est qu'il ya des causes
institutionnels cet article interroge
les raisons de la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration
dans un contexte de revalorisation
symbolique de viser qu'une déclinèrent
parce que tu es quand même sur une
société aujourd'hui dans laquelle on
valorise à fond le fait de faire la
cuisine quoi à partir d'une enquête
consacrée à la formation des petites
mains du secteur l'analyse montre
comment le lycée hôtelier détournent une
partie alors j'adore quand c'est trash
comme ça donc c'est le lycée qui
détourne vraiment une partie des
diplômés du monde professionnel et
suscite des aspirations professionnelles
d ajuster donc créé des attentes
voilà qui ne correspondent pas à la
réalité favorisant des sorties précoces
du métier focaliser sur l'apprentissage
du service des classes supérieures en
plus tu vois ya un côté lutte des
classes mais dans une version dévoyé
désuète l'enseignement implique
d'entreprendre un processus de
conversion des dispositions des élèves
issus des petites classes moyennes et
des classes populaires stabilisé du pôle
économique de l'espace social et éloigné
du monde de la restauration
ce processus passe par l'incorporation
d'un sens pratique le dressage décor un
de plus formatage des corps et
l'adoption d'un rapport au travail
vantant le don de soi bâle a du coup
fait un beau lien avec notre lecture du
jour la complexité de ce processus
couplée au manque de moyens
institutionnels pour l'appliquer
explique que son acquisition soit
limitée à un petit nombre d'élèves aux
dispositions spécifiques et qui en outre
ne possède pas les codes actualisée du
luxe bon déjà c'est dubourdieu parce qu
on est dans la revue les actes de la
recherche en sciences sociales qui est
une revue de bourdier bourdieusien créé
par bruges donc déjà ça moi ça me plaît
parce que j'adore évidemment bourdieu
est ici bon le côté dévoilement de trucs
tu vois où finalement il ya du désert
justement où finalement l'école fait
plus de mal que de bien le côté aussi
voit la
valorisation de l'activité culinaire
actuellement aussi le fait un peu des
classes des gens qui vont exploiter
d'autres personnes
le formatage décor tout ça moi c'est des
thèmes qui me parle j'ai trop envie de
lire cet article et donc ça sera notre
lecture de dimanche donc si ça vous
intéresse rendez vous dimanche 21h sinon
ce sera mardi prochain probablement pour
une lecture de marx ou de turckheim à
21h sur la société que messieurs
mesdames je vous remercie je vous salue
je vous souhaite le plus grand bien et
je vous dis à très bientôt sur la
société ciao